part three of chilling adventures has
finally arrived with Sabrina taking hell
under new management and doubling her
efforts against dangerous new cosmic
threats to Greendale
yippee guy moving lovers I'm John and in
this video I'll be discussing the
mind-blowing finale of chilling
Adventures of Sabrina part 3 and how
Sabrina changed her destiny forever plus
I'll explain what was unleashed in the
very final scene and everything to
expect in part 4 there will of course be
spoilers ahead so take care if you're
not all caught up part 3 of chilling
adventures is perhaps the most
complicated season so far
with Sabrina using time travel to undo
the apocalyptic catastrophe that unfolds
in the final two episodes so first we
need to quickly recap what happened in
an attempt to secure Hell against her
challenger Caliban and gain control over
the three and holy regalia Sabrina left
her family and friends just as they were
most vulnerable while she was away
tragedy struck Greendale as Father
Blackwood invaded the Spellman mortuary
killing prudence member Marie and Zelda
meanwhile pagans abducted Sabrina's
friends to use as human sacrifices for
the great flowering ceremony to summon
their Green Man God and Sabrina herself
was tricked into handing over the final
item of the unholy regalia to Caliban
who then entombed her in the ninth
circle of hell decades later a Sabrina
from the future arrives in the ninth
circle to free the young witch from her
stony prison by swapping places with her
the newly liberated Sabrina returns to
Greendale with the unholy regalia and
discovers the only person she knows left
alive is Ambrose who explains that the
pagans now rule the mortal realm and a
harvesting human blood to feed the green
man Ambrose still has the time egg he
stole from Blackwood and together they
use it along with the magical energy
from the unholy regalia in a time-travel
spell
Sabrina travels back several decades
suggest before the catastrophe knowing
what's about to happen she reaches her
family and friends before Blackwood and
the pagans and teleports them to safety
at Dorian's gray room she also hatches a
plan to defeat the pagans which involves
hedge which pester using a glamour to
masquerade as miss ward while he's
placed in the Green Man statue as a
virgin sacrifice Pesta then infects the
plant god statue causing it to rot and
die preventing the great flowering for
ever happening with her friends family
and Greendale saved and a catastrophic
future averted Sabrina knows she has to
return to the ninth circle of hell
because as future Sabrina told her when
you're done it'll be your turn my turn
to what to be me to do this I've gotta
go there's a promise I have to keep but
this wouldn't be chilling adventures
without Sabrina ignoring the rules and
advice she's given even by herself in
this case so she goes back to the ninth
circle but with something else in mind
she intercepts the past version of
herself and warns her she's about to be
tricked by Caliban basically Sabrina
figures that if she stops herself from
ever being trapped in the ninth circle
then she can avoid having to swap back
with the imprisoned future Sabrina
because her thinking is she never gets
trapped this creates a huge time paradox
which likes Blayne in just a moment but
to mix things up further when the
intercepted Sabrina suggests they should
merge back into a single Sabrina our
original Sabrina instead reveals she has
a plan for them both to get what they
want
as a way of reconciling her dual nature
and balancing her own conflicting
desires original Sabrina decides to have
her cake and eat it by allowing a double
of herself to exist so one can be in
hell while the other is on earth now by
the end of part three we essentially
have a set of Sabrina twins something
that was foreshadowed right in the very
first episode of season one if you've
watched my previous Sabrina videos
you'll know our eyes that when Sabrina
had a vision of two babies in the woods
one with cloven hooves and another with
human feet it hinted at Sabrina having a
secret twin of course that vision could
have simply been a metaphor for
Sabrina's dual heritage but now we see
it was more than that and did actually
hint at the future existence of two
Sabrina's Sabrina herself is unfazed by
the implications of this and rebels in
the doubling of herself when she bows to
Caliban because I'm one step ahead of
you and twice the monarch you could ever
be now if you're anything like Ambrose
you might be rolling your eyes at
Sabrina's evident disregard for
maintaining a stable timeline if you
never filled your role and freed
yourself in the first place the further
two of you you you have created a good
paradox cool no no no do know the
ramifications of this aah
are horrifying at best Ambrose is
technically correct as logically if
Sabrina has changed the future so that
she was never trapped then future
Sabrina would never have come back to
free her and our original Sabrina would
never have been able to go back in time
save Greendale and intercept herself
Sabrina's own actions could put the
stability of her timeline in danger and
something akin to Back to the Future the
movie which future Sabrina referenced
when she came back to set original
Sabrina free
in fact the future Marty has to be
careful not to interfere too much with
events in the past such as his parents
getting together and when he temporarily
puts that in jeopardy whose own
existence becomes threatened future
Sabrina already warned original Sabrina
about this just remember when you're
done with everything you have to come
back to right here right now and do what
I just did to complete the time look
it's the only way to keep the wrongs
preserved if you don't it could be chaos
chaos of course is to be expected in
this show I mean the show's acronym
almost spells out the word in English
and does so completely in Spanish a
lovely little detail from creator
Roberto aguirre-sacasa and as Ambrose
pointed out to Sabrina everything else
consequences and there are always since
one of those loose ends that everyone
including Ambrose seems to have
forgotten is revealed in the very final
scene of part three and it's a major
consequence of altering the past in this
new timeline Blackwood has actually
managed to get back both the time egg
and his twin son and daughter to
understand why Blackwood now has the egg
we need to think back to what happened
when he went to the spellman house in
search of the time egg that Ambrose and
prudence had stolen from him in the
original apocalyptic timeline Blackwood
killed prudence mumbo Marie and Zelda
when he broke into the house but just
before dying
prudence begged Ambrose to stop
Blackwood's plan by keeping the time egg
away from him so Ambrose hid the egg in
the Greendale minds until Sabrina
returned decades later and used it for
the time-travel spell in the new
timeline Sabrina prevents the death of
prudence member Marie and Zelda and
they're teleported together with Ambrose
to safety at Dorian's gray room what
everyone forgot though is that this time
when Blackwood breaks into the house
there's nobody there to stop him from
stealing back the time egg and finding
work his children are hidden and so with
the time egg in hand we see black woods
summon the eldritch terrors he talked
about so much this season here the birth
cries of this abomination and tear
through the skin of reality Blackwood
continues the ritual and pierces the
time egg with a dagger which releases an
unseen monster we hear shrieks a snarl
and some chittering sounds as one of the
eldritch terrors of Blackwood ceremony
summoned is let loose in the Greendale
woods to properly understand the nature
of the beast that Blackwood has summoned
we need to jump back to the second
episode when Ambrose and prudence
tracked Blackwood down to his hiding
place in Loch Ness Scotland at the lake
Blackwood summoned a creature he called
the deep one which is a term that's been
used for a group of water dwelling
humanoids in the literature of HP
Lovecraft the deep one which rises out
of the lake brings black with the time
eggs that will later give birth to the
eldritch terror the deep ones are also
part of Lovecraft's Cthulhu Mythos were
there kept in check by the magic of the
old gods but with the pagans and their
old gods defeated and shunning
adventures new timeline the door is now
open for Lovecraft him monsters to enter
the world this will be interesting to
see how these eldritch beings and their
powers are portrayed on screen in the
show as in Lovecraft's work the idea is
that simply gazing upon a cosmic entity
like Cthulhu will drive an ordinary
human insane a concept that was also
used for the monsters in the Netflix
movie bird box
Blackwood references this idea somewhat
when he refers to the creature he plans
to unleash as unspeakable these eldritch
creatures also likely come from an
entirely different dimension in fact
Ambrose already suspected that Blackwood
was hiding in an alternate reality of
sorts when they were searching for him
at the start of the season someone who
could be anywhere in the world if not
another dimension and Blackwood
deliberately chose Loch Ness in Scotland
for his hideout because of its special
location Loch Ness know that of a
powerful rift and only a slay lines
Aleister Crowley himself once harnesses
energies for his own higher magics magic
the very fabric of time and space
Blackwood himself seems to have
in some time manipulation while at Loch
Ness because when prudence and Ambrose
find him and his children in the space
of just a month they've grown from
babies into teenagers at fifteen years
inside a temporal church of my own
creation the threat that these eldritch
monsters may pose to not just the mortal
realm but also hell if not heaven as
well is already felt by two characters
in the final episode mumbo Marie senses
something wrong in the air and tell
Zelda we must harness your coven Schmitt
turn up waffle protection prepare down
for more and over in hell Sabrina
prepares for her formal coronation as
Queen Lilith tells her every Queen must
be made battle ready every girl must be
para for more Lilith is probably sensing
the incoming interdimensional threat
that the eldritch terrors represent but
I also wonder whether will see heaven
getting involved in this conflict indeed
there was a little tease to this briefly
by Zelda in part three honestly first
purgatory now helmets next to heaven and
in the original apocalyptic timeline
heaven decided to intervene after the
armies of Hell attack the pagans on
earth so it's quite possible we'll see
another heavenly intervention if hell
interferes in the earthly clash against
the eldritch terrors alternatively or
perhaps as well heaven can get involved
in trying to remedy any possible
instability caused by the time paradox
created by Sabrina you have to come back
to complete the time look it's the only
way to keep the roms preserved
fortunately to combat this new cosmic
terror that's coming in part for Sabrina
seems to be leveling up with each new
season update I have more power than I
did before by the end of part three
she's able to teleport between hell and
earth without any special spell or
portal like the one she needed from
Dorian in the first episode
another new ability she seems to have is
persuasion where she can convince
another person to believe something
Sabrina uses this with Lucy Anderson's
mother when she and Roz are looking for
clues to the girl's whereabouts you
wouldn't mind if we took one of Lucy's
pinwheels with us would you
yeah
you wouldn't mind at all who wouldn't
mind at all
Star Wars fans might see this is a Power
similar to a Jedi mind-trick
these aren't the droids you're looking
for on top of that Sabrina's eyes go
white when she tells Caliban to back off
this seems to indicate that when lilith
restores Sabrina's powers at the end of
Part two
the young witch also got back the powers
she inherited from her father Lucifer
which saw her resurrect from the dead
levitate and burn people alive I am the
Dark Lord's charge as for Sabrina's love
life well things didn't turn out so
great for her in part three although she
rescued Nick from Hell the after-effects
of being one with the Dark Lord made him
feel he could no longer be with Sabrina
because he saw too much of Lucifer her
father and her and when she goes to
perform a cord-cutting spell to
permanently remove any feeling she has
for Nick
Salem brings up Harvey despite claiming
she only loves Harvey platonically
Sabrina quickly realizes that she still
does have romantic feelings for him as
well so she adds Harvey's name to the
candle and performs a spell it's a
painful moment for Sabrina and imply she
may be mostly loveless in part for
something that lilith also mentioned
while preparing Sabrina to become queen
of hell let nothing touch him like no
man home power oh for you a small
question I have though is whether the
cord cutting spell actually worked a
Sabrina added two names to the candle
fans of Sabrina and Harvey eventually
getting back together also had their
hopes dashed when Sabrina herself said
to Harvey that he and Rose are destined
for each other
you guys run game an important change by
the end of part three is that the
Greendale cover no longer worships the
dark Lord but has now become the order
of Hegarty early in the season Zelda
realizes that it makes no sense to
continue worshipping Lucifer when he's
deliberately causing the coven's powers
to weaken by withholding his powers as
punishment for their part in trapping
him inside Nick's body but it's not
until Zelda's shot and enters the nether
realm aka limbo that she finally
discovers the solution to restoring the
coven's powers when she sees the three
pictures of the new moon half moon and
full moon during a vision of her own
death zelda understand
only hacker teen 3 formed goddess has
the power to restore the coven that's
are you now if not the Church of Knight
the order of Haggerty worshiping the
three-in-one
I think Haggerty could come into play as
well in season 4 as part of restoring
the balance between realms and defeating
the eldritch terrors in classical
mythology Haggerty has acted as a
goddess of boundaries and as a mediator
between the divine and the mortal realms
she was thought to have the power to
either prevent or allow dangerous
spirits to pass through entrances in
chilling adventures when zelda leads the
covenant prayer to the goddess Hecate ii
is able to bring hilda back to the world
of the living and conversely she may be
able to help banish the eldritch terrors
back to their own dimension as a
mediator Hegarty could also assist in
any dispute between heaven and hell or
earth perhaps over how to handle to
Sabrina's existing at the same time
something that season 3 expanded on was
the connections and easter eggs to
Riverdale in fact the show even reveals
some dark backstory about the origins of
the blossoms maple syrup business tap in
the top right for a full breakdown of
that and many other details you might
have missed such as the hidden clue that
told us right from the beginning that
Robin Goodfellow was a Hobgoblin there's
also a link to that in the video
description so what do you think of part
3 and Sabrina doubling herself leave
your thoughts and any theories you have
about part 4 in the comments below next
tap left for all the amazing details you
might have missed in part 3 or tap right
for another video you're sure to LIKE
and if you enjoyed this a thumbs up and
a shirt hugely appreciated thanks for
watching and see you next time you pick
a movie lovers